today we're going to talk about estrogen
in relationship to the female cycle
something that's extremely common yet
very misunderstood so let's just break
it down first of all let's talk about
what a hormone is hormones are
communications that are created and sent
through the blood system so they're
created by the gland sent to the blood
and they connect into a part of the
tissue that has receptors for that
specific hormone like right now I'm
talking to you through the computer into
your speaker into your ear and you're
receiving that information if I was
speaking another language that would be
like a different hormone so the receiver
has to understand the language for what
it's being received by so estrogen has
receptors in the liver and the uterus in
the bone in the brain in there in the
ovary so it can even go from over your
ovary as well so basically we have the
glands and glands the difference between
a gland in Oregon is glands make
hormones organs don't with the exception
of the liver the liver does make a
hormone so but typically glands make
hormones sent to the blood and get
received over here to create some effect
so hormones are communications the one
we're going to talk about today is
estrogen every month one of your ovaries
runs the show and sends the hormones
into the into the bud blood on a four
28-day cycle so at day 14 you have this
spike of estrogen and then it goes down
and this is ovulation when you're the
most fertile and then another hormone
that the ovary produces called
progesterone increases as well and then
a date 28 that's when you have the
menstrual cycle and then the sync starts
over and over and over again so based on
when you have the problem during the
28-day cycle we can kind of tell where
the where your issue is because a lot of
women a week before their period start
getting like they feel like they're
pregnant and they're just like all this
fluid retention their belly sticks out
well we know that's progesterone versus
estrogen if the problem is during
ovulation then we know it's definitely
estrogen if it's during your cycle we
know it's estrogen
so the effects that estrogen create in
the cell whether it's the liver the
uterus or wherever where the breast
tissue can create effective breasts the
size of the breast that's why if there's
a problem with estrogen you can have
tenderness in the breasts or cysts in
the breast the uterus the menstrual
cycle your sex drive the DNA so estrogen
affects the DNA the transcription of the
of the blueprints so estrogen can send
the message into the DNA and intel parts
of your body to grow and get bigger all
right so that's why it affects the DNA
and that's why I can create tumors we'll
get to that in a little bit
estrogen affects the shape of your body
it feminized --iz the body and that's
why it gives that the lower part the
hips a shape it gives the curve on a
female body that's why women have a
layer of fat a superficial fat that men
don't have in the lower part of their
bodies well some men do but most don't
so gives you the shape and so if there's
too much estrogen you're going to get
too much heavy lower part of your body
the bone it affects the bone it affects
the cognitive the brain it affects the
electrolytes cuz in the kidneys the
potassium sodium ratio so you can see it
has many many different effects but the
function of the ovary is to send
hormones into different parts and then
one month the one of the ovaries will do
do all the work and then the other month
the other ovary does the alt the
produces the ovulation so they alternate
back and forth between left and right
ovaries so depending on what part of
your body you have a little back pain on
it could be like the right lower part of
the back the next week it's like no pain
and then it could be the right side then
we know the right ovary could be
producing too much estrogen so what they
alternate or even sometimes you'll get
acne on the one side of your face versus
the other side so again the ovary
produces these hormones that create all
sorts of different effects in the body
now probably the most common problem
with the ovary is the over production of
estrogen they call it estrogen dominance
it's too much estrogen what happens with
too much estrogen you're going to get
excessively heavy periods cramping no
periods irregular periods or irregular
cycles
long periods heavy bleeding every single
problem with that period will be
disrupted with too much estrogen and one
of the one of the triggers for too much
estrogen we'll get into the next part
but it could be a low progesterone
because if the estrogen causes no
periods there's nothing to trigger the
progesterone release and so therefore
the pedestrian goes down even more and
then the relative ratio of estrogen goes
up like a teeter-totter
so estrogen and progesterone work like
this so when you don't have much of this
this kind of goes up in the relative
ratios just like salt and potassium so
if you have too much salt your potassium
is going to go down same effect so
estrogen can cause no periods and then
there's no progesterone and then that
makes more estrogen so it's kind of a an
interesting thing okay headaches come
from too much estrogen fluid retention
can come from estrogen dominance
fibroids endometriosis which is extra
growth of tissue in the female cavity
through here can come from estrogen
dominance as well and because remember
we talked about DNA DNA it's affects the
blueprints it makes tissue grow it
increases the size of different things
so fibroids definitely come from
estrogen dominance cysts come from
estrogen dominance and you can have
cysts on the ovaries you can have on the
breast and that could that comes from
estrogen dominance as well gall stones
why because estrogen concentrates the
cholesterol in the gall bladder they're
thereby creating stones so gall stones
are real common trigger from high levels
of estrogen and they usually see them
after pregnant
see simply because the spike of estrogen
during the cycle in the pregnancy okay
then we have cancer too much estrogen
can trigger cancer and that's why one of
the medications they use as an
anti-cancer blocker would be tamoxifen
which blocks the receptors for estrogen
decreasing the risks so cancer is
definitely triggered by too much
estrogen and then the thyroid can be
diminished with too much estrogen why
because the thyroid also has receptors
for I'll try to draw a little tiny
picture here receptors for estrogen so
if there's too much thyroid surgery in
the body it can block the receptors in
the thyroid and now not let the thyroid
hormones get in there thereby decreasing
the function of the thyroid so we have a
secondary low thyroid called hypothyroid
coming from an estrogen dominant
situation and that's why you see a lot
of women with thyroid problems after
pregnancy after being exposed to a lot
of estrogen so I would this is my guess
I would say most thyroid cases are this
problem right here not primary so those
are some of the effects that estrogen
dominance can create on the body so the
next question is what causes estrogen
dominance well the first thing is our
environmental first of all we are in
environment that's so bathed with so
much estrogen that I mean it's
everywhere it's and the pesticides
insecticides herbicides fungicides heavy
metals country-and-western
I'm just a bad joke and then you have D
DT now DDT was banned in 1971 yet we
finding it in in our adipose tissue or
fat tissue even in kids why because
we're not able to use it in the US but
we're able to sell it at third world
countries will we buy our fruits and
vegetables in the winter so it comes
right back and goes right into our body
DDT mimics estrogen so environmentally
they call it endocrine disrupters which
are really chemicals in the environment
that mimic estrogen and our cell
can receive or pickup the tissues can
receive these chemicals and they connect
like estrogen and that's why a lot of
the books on toxicology the study of
poisons show the relationship between
these chemicals pesticides and things
and hormone disruption so we have that
number one HRT hormone replacement here
used to be called estrogen replacement
therapy but they found estrogen causes
cancer so what they did is they add a
little bit of progesterone to buffer it
which did decrease the cancer risk by
some amount and then they call it
hormone replacement therapy but these
estrogens that are synthetic which are
by made from horse urine pregnant horses
are a lot different than our bodies our
bodies as humans were not designed to be
exposed to horse estrogens so it does
create a lot of problems for females
when they have to take HRT and then
birth control pills estrogen the next
one is soy specifically soy protein
isolates 95 percent of soy protein
isolates are genetically modified but
they're putting the this type of protein
is kind of a new protein and and the
breakfast cereals and the baby food in
the protein bars and the diet shakes a
lot of these diets use the soy protein
lysis because it's a cheap type of
protein dr. McDougall MD has found that
soy protein isolates can influence
fibroids and tumors in the liver okay
progesterone decreases we talked about
that in the last section really when you
start losing your period around
premenopause or perimenopause i'm sorry
you can then have a problem with
decreased progesterone and relative
increase estrogen because they work on a
reciprocal basis so that can also be one
of the problems that we're dealing with
and so we also have liver problems now
the liver is where you actually detoxify
estrogen too much of it so if that
livers healthy you can get rid of a lot
of extra estrogen but if you're starting
at constipation and
Galba problems and liver toxicity
because your diets really crappy you're
not going to be able to break down this
excess estrogen and that can be another
culprit to estrogen dominance so these
are some of the common causes of
estrogen dominance so I want to make one
point about menopause I have a lot of
clients that tell me well I'm running
out of estrogen because I'm going
through menopause so therefore I need to
take Astra j'en in the thoughts that if
they don't they're going to end up with
Alzheimer's Bastia Prosis and get really
old and heart disease in fact there's
very little research of that I would
love to find some research so the next
time someone tells you that asks for the
research it's not really there see you
have a backup organ during menopause the
adrenal glands on top of your kidney
produce the same hormones as the ovaries
do not in the same quantity but the same
hormones so what's supposed to happen
naturally in nature is the ovaries shut
down or they stop working and then all
this work is done on the adrenals what
we're seeing is this people going into
menopause with burnt out adrenals
everything they're not able to back up
those ovaries effectively and then they
end up with all these problems with hot
flashes night sweats and vaginal dryness
and a lot of weight gain because now the
adrenals have to work harder and they
get this bigger stomach and belly fat so
really if there's a problem with
adrenals before menopause it's
exaggerated after menopause okay so they
go from one problem to a worse problem
and then people take what's called they
start taking hormones and the problem
there's side effects to that and even
the bioidentical hormones here's the
problem I have with taking bio tentacle
hormones remember we talked about the
gland that makes hormones hormones are
the communications the gland is the
thing that makes the hormones and it's
sent over here to something else instead
of focusing on the hormone where
basically the problem is not really the
hormone it's the gland very few people
support the thing that makes the hormone
because when you take even by identical
hormones you actually inactivate your
own gland that makes that hormone same
thing with the thyroid and you take in
thyroid medication or
our hormones your Glenn doesn't have to
produce so it goes to sleep over time
you shrivel it up so that's why I'm not
crazy about people jumping and start
taking hormones because you're going to
then shut down your own body's ability
to make it what you should do is take a
look at how you can support the Klan
okay we'll get to that in the next
section okay so now what do we do about
this there are four solutions that I
recommend phytoestrogens that that would
be all those vegetables that people
never eat like the cruciferous
vegetables kale broccoli Brussels
sprouts cabbage those foods are anti
Astra genic which means they help
balance your estrogens they're not going
to decrease the good estrogens they're
going to balance any bad and they
protect against cancer so and again as
far as the solution this is my
disclaimer I'm not telling you that any
of these will help you with any diseases
will prevent any diseases I'm not
telling you these are going to treat a
disease so check with your doctor with
that that's my disclaimer okay these are
just things that can help support a
healthy menstrual cycle okay all right
so we got phytoestrogens very few people
have enough of those I highly recommend
start eating those that's why the kale
shake is so important if you have not
done the calcic go to dr. Byrd calm the
front page and scroll down and download
that eating plan because it's shows you
how to make the kale shakes every
morning it's a no-brainer everyone
should be on that Cal shake avoid
estrogens well here's the thing I'm not
telling you to come off your medication
check with your doctor but start
avoiding estrogens in the in the food
supply you have hormones and all the
butter that cheese the milk the dairy
the beef the chicken the turkey so have
foods that are hormone free all right
because there's estrogen in those foods
also have more organic vegetables now if
you cannot afford it at least don't buy
the ones from Chile in Mexico buy
vegetables that are in the country that
way you don't get the DDT all right
because you don't know if there's DDT on
there or not it's just a big mystery so
we want to avoid estrogens we want to
support the gland so I created something
that I've been using in my clinic to
support a healthy ovary and uterus
because it supports both and I don't
know if you can see it that far but it's
called ovary support formula and this is
what I recommend for clients just to
help balance things and improve things
overall and then mate and for a
maintenance as well so I recommend three
of these and they are a nutritional
blend that supports not just the ovaries
but the uterus as well and it doesn't
have estrogen it it has nutrients that
that target the gland itself okay so we
want to support the gland and then we
want to eat foods that support the liver
and that's why in my book the seven
principles of fat burning I talked the
first eating planet everyone does is
deliver enhancement why because that way
we can support the liver the liver can
then balance any excess of estrogen that
shouldn't be there so the foods that
support the liver also support estrogen
because there are certain things in the
liver that regulate estrogen or buffer
excessive toxic amounts of estrogen so
those are four very simple things you
should focus on to help your situation
and your cycle